hello and welcome to this video play
DeMarcus I am DeMarcus okay no got no
name mentioned again but kind of my TAS
go against them minus one ok let's is 60
that's not very common to set up we'll
see what happens hmm Tim she wants to go
for you five that's that's really not
what I want to see him ok hmm ok goon
felt type of position yeah I wonder if
95 is correct him maybe I can do that he
takes before no this is I didn't think
of hmm ok
so I can go h3r and 95 is sometimes an
issue here if 395 takes d4 Knight f3
this kind of thing but it should be
should be good ready so I'm pushing this
bag first has to go to f5
yeah this is bishop doesn't have any
squares if I go even f4 is interesting
also just pawn takes it's not bad Queen
diff 25 is not that convincing it's got
nine txt five I guess okay I'm keeping
it so I'm taking too much time here to
try to refute his play and instead I
could just do something like this which
is better for wide and two ND easy to
play just a better central control IAM
should have played that a lot quicker
m idea is just e 4 and f for expanding
in the in the center quite sure yeah
this kind of thing I came going at 45 as
planned ok is his play is based on on
tactical ideas f for Queen B 6 and then
I'd see form so let's get out of the
check yeah f-4s possibly d4 I think I'm
taking with this it's not quite clear so
I Bishop f5 okay interesting
damn damn people interesting play that
in an interesting way we are constantly
playing for tricks and like 94 I don't
mean that in a negative way just how
this is working off and you have to
justify your play tactically okay I'm
going out of this at least you have
night a form hmm not sure it's the best
though anyway you need to speed up okay
trade this attack to quickly maybe they
also was Adam they also rather move
Queenie for for example okay I think
this is particularly bad
I go look give one west the night going
he also has a check I think I'll go here
g4s Queen d6 chick but it still would be
would be good right f g4 is a threat now
see going for h5 or something i also
have to ship before the night is
slightly stranded Teague's take screen F
to the screen d for ice queen of six oh
shoot it's got Queen f6 shy damn it damn
it check and it saves a um ahh how
stupid check ok now sport this very good
position
ya know I'm in bad shape
time warning ninety-four what's the
problem
okay check and probably not to go ahead
nor the move actually check check check
check check check check check check
check check yeah Danielle hotel is very
stupid loss I just blundered the Dead
Queen f6 move here black isn't pretty
pretty bad trouble yeah bishop f1 you
can resign off casa yeah i was i was
airplane losing men yeah he just played
in a very very tactical way always
trying to justify some ambitious moves
which is probably all right up to here
but he got into trouble from here
somehow Queen d3 is what the engine is
giving and this should be too ambitious
really now yeah why this already clearly
better he has no way out of this all out
for this night night before the screen
deform I more or less winning here and
after that Bishop f1's just resignation
just winning the piece yeah but I
overlooked I thought that I'm winning
the night anyway it has no squares it's
just that
overlooked that he has got Queen f6 i
was thinking i win the night anyway with
bishop before so instead but should have
won he just has to resign you know hi
what a shame yeah he played this opening
here night xe5 is just very very bad
move that leads to that you should lead
to trouble like this this and I probably
have to change the move over here a
little bit I have to play a foreign the
computer says that f four winds just
like that so the chapters oh I
completely forgot who gave to of course
yeah I was just thinking about King move
after King movie has nights he fried his
idea works perfectly but I have just
this oh and this is the end of the game
basically can I g-form okay and this is
this is more or less winning for white
and yeah so it's his fancy play could
have been punished more than once didn't
see it this is too lame and now he's
okay again now ya missed miss two big
chances there to win in a technical way
this is thought of something that isn't
you to my games but um yeah it should
have had a different result if I was
more um alert in those two situations
okay thanks for watching